hey everybody I'm miles Lasher and we're
backstage here with one of our all-time
favorite guests congressman Barney Frank
welcome back it's a real time so how'd
you feel about the show tonight oh I
enjoyed it a lot
I learned from the water expert that was
you know an important piece of it and
Bill was very funny as usual yeah it's a
huge issue going on now you know one
thing absolutely it's know people don't
don't see it yet and it's important to
bring things to people's attention that
haven't yet manifested themselves so
they can deal with it
exactly and you were here tonight with a
new book Frank and you're always Frank
the Charles always funny you killed it
on the show tonight very true and that's
also a really big part of this book I
mean you are one of them well one things
I talk about in the book is that if you
can use rumor and I've been lucky guy
you know I have no sense of direction
I'm not I have no nothing good with the
cattle things i lucky enough to have a
good sense of humor you're trying to get
a point across and people are inundated
with material if you can make it funny
then won't like me to remember it and so
that becomes an important part of the
messaging was there a point that you
realize that you had a gift for this
sort of thing yeah well cool yeah when I
was in school I could make the other
kids behalf and I could piss off the
teachers and when did you start to I
mean it wasn't always part of your
political life because yeah I'm kind of
a defining yeah I was you know I just
one thing I get bored if I can't fool
around but then I realize it was an
effective political tool one you know
people are like to be ridiculed so him
adds to that well maybe I'd better not
argue with him secondly as I said it
people remember the point and I'll give
an example I thought there was a
terrible inconsistency with the right
wingers like Reagan saying we'll get out
more abortion but then trying to
dismantle every program that helped poor
children if these women had to give
birth to them and I said apparently in
their view from the federal government
standpoint life begins at conception but
it ends birth and frankly I believe that
actually had an impact in persuading
some of the right to life people that
they were wrong to cut things like
women's and infants and children program
well you're a fantastic and just
completely disarming people
with your humor was there somebody that
was like a comedic inspiration I loved
the the verbal comics and by the way
some people have done a documentary
about me and they call it compared to
what which is something I borrowed from
a man and Henny Youngman he was called
the king of the one-liners right now in
the 40s 50s and 60s humor was based in
part on guys making fun of their wives
mothers in law they don't want to get
married or handed and he was famous for
yeah take my way take my wife please
actually the other one that I recently
saw was I've lost my wife in a wishing
well who knew they worked but he had one
that wasn't just and something was that
you quite profound how's your wife
compared to what and that became my
mantra anytime I had to make a decision
do we do this is this acceptable
compared to what because in public life
you don't have the luxury of molding
something brand-new you got to deal with
the reality and so early on that that
became a way to me for me both to
justify we need to make hard choices and
be funny about it and I just have one
more question about your book you
managed to get former Treasury secretary
Hank Paulson and Elizabeth Warren to
write blurbs on the back here how'd you
manage that I'm very proud of it
basically by being sensible and yeah I'm
a partisan Democrat I start with a
liberal position but I also believe
there's a need from there see if you can
negotiate and and I'm very proud that
these two people who were seen as very
different on their somewhat in common
more than people think both sort of work
were approving of my work Americana
would you like to see senator Warren ran
for president no I think she's right not
to do that she's a very powerful force
for good for protecting financial reform
she understands if she began to even hit
the huge run for president her
credibility would get destroyed the
meeting would start picking apart and at
this point they really are not nearly as
many differences between her and Hillary
Clinton as people might think I Hillary
Clinton is representative of a broad
consensus on liberal values and if we
were to focus on a few differences
rather than getting together
that general program we'd weaken
ourselves what about you are you running
well I will be 75 in a week and thinking
that I was too old to be in Congress
that would suddenly kind of bloom out
president and and well my husband Jimmy
you filled with energy you can handle
that my husband Jim has been well you
now you don't know what it'll be like
four years later my husband Jim has
adapted remarkably to the political
world but I I think being the first man
would probably try to deface it all even
if that check out Frank it's on the
bookshelves now Thank You congressman
thank you so much much appreciated
you